[Musique]
françois bayrou bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous maire de pau président
du modem haut commissaire au plan
françois bayrou nous allons parler
évidemment proportionnelle vous y tenez
vote anticipé séparatisme relance
économique islam au gauchisme mais
mollesse de marine le pen aussi mais je
voudrais commencer avec l'épidémie
coheed 19 stable pour l'instant le
président de la république a fait le bon
choix
il a fait un choix très courageux et
contre beaucoup beaucoup de spécialistes
entre guillemets qui recommandait le au
contraire le confinement
moi j'ai toujours pensé vous savez que
on peut pas mais on ne peut pas mettre
un pays sous cloche sauf conditions qui
sont des conditions extrêmes ça a été
fait on attend dernier oui mais
peut-être fallait-il à cette époque vous
souvenez au printemps dernier oui on
pensait que les que d'un que cette
épidémie
c'était une épidémie qui ensuite allait
s'arrêter un as we put démis en une
seule vague puis on s'est aperçu que ce
n'était pas vrai et on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que peut-être on est devant
une question que que nous avons étudié
avec le commissariat au plan que qui est
si le vide du ray mais on voit bien en
tout cas qu'il y à une issue et une
seule à cette épidémie c'est la
vaccination
on voit bien que la question de la
vaccination est une question au fond
extrêmement simple elle dépend
uniquement du nombre de doses de vaccins
disponibles donc de la production
industrielle de la production
industrielle un pays comme le nôtre
anne tous les moyens de vacciner aussi
largement qu'on le voudra
dès l'instant que
les doses de vaccin existe je prends en
exemple à nous de les produire le prends
un exemple simple il ya vingt-deux mille
pharmaciens beau ici en france oui si
chacun de ses vingt-deux mille fait sans
vaccination par mois eh bien on se
trouve à d'un seul coup d'un seul 2
million deux cent mille de plus qui sont
vaccinées et tout ça sans compter les
hôpitaux les cliniques alors produisons
les vaccins en france et en europe et
bien le vent lui vite possible ils ont
les vaccins moi je suis heureux parce
que nous allons avoir à pau une unité de
production des vaccins
réalisé par une entreprise française de
production de mise en condition et de
conditionnement des vaccins
il y aura trois ou quatre sites en
france je suis très heureux que l'on
puisse à pau en produire des centaines
de milliers bien françois bayrou
bon pour l'instant la situation était
sous contrôle en fin sous contrôle
l'épidémie est stable en tout cas les
chiffres jugés encourageants bon
l'épidémie est stable mais si par hasard
comme le disent beaucoup beaucoup
d'infections log
si par hasard l'épidémie remonter s'il y
avait une poussée épidémique que faire
confinement nationale ou déconfinement
locaux dd com c'est une stratégie la
stratégie zéro co lead l'allemagne
d'ailleurs est en train d'épouser cette
stratégie c'est ce qui se fait en
australie en nouvelle zélande jeunesse
et au vietnam c'est ce qu'on annonce qui
va se faire
et après tout c'est une bonne stratégie
ça consiste à isoler ou et les zones
orient lesquelles e
il n'y a plus de contaminations et à
rendre ces zones le plus étanche
possible de manière que c'est une bonne
solution des repas c'est la notion je ne
dis pas que c'est au moins la solution
c'est le vaccin oui pour moi la solution
le médecin pour la réouverture pour que
la ville reine oui et en je pense en
particulier aux universités oui et je
pense à la culture à tous ceux qui ont
justement événementiel nous allait
rouvrir les musées à pau
n'est pas moi je ne veux pas qu'on ai
déconné des décisions locales qu'ils
soient pas en phase avec l'échelon
national mais on est prêt à le faire on
en a parlé évidemment avec les
responsables pas faire ce qu'a fait
louis aliot à perpignan
non je vous comprenez si on n'est pas
solidaire dans une période et une crise
comme celle là si on ne réfléchit pas
tous ensemble si on essaie de faire de
la communication locale
je trouve qu'on n'est pas responsable
est ce que le festival de pau aura lieu
l'été prochain
françois bayrou alors le fest festival
dédié plusieurs festive au festival oui
si on peut évidemment et je répète que
selon moi c'est lié à la vaccination
avec six nations une forme alors une
forme de quoi de passeports vaccin est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre le savez
bien
j'ai pas trop cette expression mais ça
peut être un certificat de vaccination g
digitalisées a toujours défendu où l
idée oui que comme la vaccination est la
clé oui on pourra ré ouvrir rapidement
j'ai indiqué des secteurs d'activité dès
l'instant qu'on s'assurera que sont
vaccinés tous ceux qui veulent y
participer alors on dit passeport
certificat carte de vaccination vous
savez quand vous voulez aller en france
en guyane
oui vous êtes obligés de produire oui
une carte de vaccination pour la fièvre
jaune et personne n'a eu le sentiment
que la vaccination pour la fièvre jaune
était une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles
alors pourquoi ne retombe pas ce débat
en france est bien joli ouvert si vous
permettez au lait ou vert soutenu
je me suis fait copieusement prendre à
partie et même insulté assez sévèrement
sur les réseaux sociaux
mais bon
c'est ça le lot de ceux qui essaient de
penser un peu aux gouvernements le
gouvernement semble très réticent
françois baroin le gouvernement tient
compte de l'opinion publique il ya des
avis différents son sein mais la chance
qui est la mienne c'est que je ne suis
pas le gouvernement à l'enjeu n'a pas le
gouvernement et ça joue et je pense que
nous allons le constater
parce que sur certains points tiens par
exemple le fameux vote par anticipation
c'est une bêtise d'avoir comme ça a trop
dû rapidement un amendement au sénat
lors d'une procédure accélérée sur
l'organisation de la présidentielle de
2000 22 alors sûrement sa part de bons
sentiments
vous auriez encore noté que oui j'ai
fait la phrase de huy de consensus de
consensus mais j'arrive pas à comprendre
la manière dont ces débats naissent en
france on est devant une question que
vous savez j'ai soulevé nous avons
soulevés oui avec le mouvement démocrate
depuis des mois et des années qui est la
recherche de nouveaux moyens d'exprimer
le vote alors que l'abstention explose
l'épidémie a fait que beaucoup de gens
ne sont pas allés aux bureaux de vote
et pendant ce temps quand on regarde ce
qui se passe dans toutes les autres
démocraties du monde
oui alors on s'aperçoit qu'aux états
unis il ya plus de 100 millions 100
millions d'électeurs qui ont voté par
correspondance pour l'élection
présidentielle sur laquelle le monde
entier avait les yeux fixés et on n'a
pas pu trouver une seule une seule
suspicion en allemagne et en suisse les
élections locales se sont tenues tandis
que nous repoussons les nôtres parce
qu'ils ont le vote par correspondance
y'a rien de plus simple est de +1 sur
les principes que cette expression du
vote
il est à le vote par internet le
président de la république s'était
prononcé sur ce sur ce sujet le vote par
anticipation bon c'est pas si ça a un
avantage ou passés chez plus de points
d'interrogations que de réponses dans
mon esprit
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas une
réflexion globale sur ces sujets mais
pourquoi alors voir quoi mais bon voilà
parce que je vais vous dire je crois que
tout ça est lié au fait que nous n'avons
pas de bonnes règles de représentation
que on croit que vaudrait très froid
mais sur le fond on sera font que pour
être efficace oui il faut être
hégémonique faut avoir tous les pouvoirs
et toutes les majorités est en réalité
si vous avez tous les pouvoirs et toutes
les majorités le pays n'adhère pas et
vous ne pouvez pas entraîner ou proposer
ou imposé une seule réforme sans la
d'aisé donc un mauvais fonctionnement de
la démocratie et or c'est un
fonctionnement de la démocratie qui est
mauvaise au lu ment nuisibles nuisibles
mauvaise nuit il y à dire qu'aujourd'hui
le pouvoir concentré entre une seule
main celle du président de la république
et de sa majorité
mais françois bausch j'ai toujours été
défenseur de la fonction président
rouille non mais n'est-ce pas peut-être
on peut oui en deux phrases revenir et
en deux phrases à l'idée qu'ils étaient
celles du général de gaulle quand il a
créé la 5ème république l'a dit nous
allons enlever l'exécutif aux manoeuvres
et combinaisons parlementaire nous
allons le confier un président de la
république élu et ensuite il formera son
gouvernement écoute et bien cette phrase
entre guillemets en tenant compte des
nuances de l'assemblée nationale il
voulait dire que quand vous avez un
président élu qui a la légitimité du
pouvoir après eelv est loisible
d'élargir g qu'on peut tenir qu'on ait
retardé ce qui se passe en italie s'est
formidablement intéressant cette femme
aura noir politique formidablement
absolue monsieur draghi l'ancien
président de la banque centrale
européenne qui s'allie avec qui avec
monsieur salvini non non
comment non votre appréciation n'est pas
juste ah bon que fait mario draghi et je
trouve que c'est une expérience
formidable
réunis dans sa répond à toutes les
questions qu'on rit aux en france que
posent les adversaires de cette règle
électorale juste parce que c'est ça la
question c'est y en a pour tout le monde
soit représenté que vous soyez dans la
majorité ou dans l'opposition
oui vous avez le droit d'être
représentés que fait mario draghi
il est devant une assemblée qui est
divisée oui eh bien il réunit les forces
différentes pour former un gouvernement
d'entente la ligue
le mouvement 5 étoiles 12 heures
jusqu'au nez ou sur tous ceux qui se
sont opposés pendant des décennies oui
il dit écoutez moi je suis le chef du
gouvernement mais c'est possible en je
suis le patron mais bien sûr c'est
possible puisque nous avons un
gouvernement résidentiel gouvernement
réunissant toutes ces tendances folie
telavi bien parce que parce que vous
pouvez vous répéter ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai plaidé pendant vingt-huit jeunes en
or dès l'instant que vous avez un patron
oui et le président de la république est
un patron oui investie de la légitimité
que lui donne le suffrage de la majorité
des français c'est à lui qu'on remet le
soin de conduire l'exécutif dès
l'instant que vous avez ce patron
investi de légitimité il peut élargir
qu'est ce que c'est la proportionnelle
c'est il y a une tendance qui a le
pouvoir
mais ce mode de scrutin juste l'obligent
à tenir compte des autres à tenir compte
même de ceux qui sont dans l'opposition
bon même de ce qui sort de marie le pen
dans un gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
pour qu'on armait de vous voyez que mais
les carences et pathé carré joaillier
les caricatures en paix et de réfléchir
oui oui d'accord donc justement qu il ya
en france des majorités
oui il y à des oppositions oui vous
pourrez vérifier quelque chose aucune
des grandes lois j'allais même dire
aucune des lois marquantes qui ont été
adoptés depuis quatre ans ne l'a été
sans qu'il y ait des votes de
l'opposition pour
ou des abstentions qui lui permettent de
passer oui aucune de ces lois n'a été
imposée par la majorité contre
l'opposition
et si on si on mesure ça alors on se
rend compte que ça n'est pas tant la
majorité numérique qui compte
ce qui compte c'est d'être capable de
rassembler de rassembler regarder ce que
le président de la république vient de
faire avec sa décision sur on ne confine
rappaz contre tout le monde
oui eh bien tout d'un coup ça a suscité
un élan un soutien incessant blement
mais bayrou dans le ça ça fait des
années que vous plaidez pour celui
passionnel mais j'étais minoritaire mais
maintenant ce concept majoritaire j'en
avais parlé qu emmanuel macron ces
derniers jours tout oui oui et alors ou
est-ce que ça va se faire pour la
prochaine je n'ai qu'une seule règle
c'est des règles simples oui en quand je
parle avec le président de l'arjel chose
que j'ai je le raconte pas sur les
planches catégorie mais moi je vous pose
une question de simple est ce que pour
la législative de 2022
ça va se faire en tout cas c'est sur ce
point que je me bats et ses transferts
que je veux aller et quand je mène un
combat c'est parce que je crois qu'on
peut le gagner
vous allez y arriver j'espère je crois
sincèrement oui sincèrement sincèrement
penser que représente la république
aujourd'hui et tel écoute je pense
qu'ils l'écoutent je pense que c'est un
problème qu'il nous regarde là je suis
sûr qu'ils ne regardent en se garent à
côté de son bureau le télévision est
allumée sur votre jeu
oui quand vous avez oui une promesse de
campagne
oui que cette promesse est soutenu par
la majorité des forces politiques du
pays
oui quelle est la seule condition pour
changer la manière dont on gouverne et
les rapports entre le pouvoir et le nuit
et que ça ne coûte rien
quelle raison y aurait-il de ne pas le
faire ans à bayrou est ce que vous
trouvez vous avez vu peut-être une
déclaration ville ya une force politique
qui doit par nature ou par contradition
favorable c'est elle
r mais gérard longuet qui est une des
figures les plus importantes de ce
courant politique et les plus
expérimentés gérard longuet il a dit
écoutez c'est le seul moyen de changer
la manière dont on gouverne la france et
on en a follement besoin puisque le pays
tout entier se détournent des urnes et
se détournent de l'attention à ce qui se
passe à l'assemblée nationale alors si
c'est bien pas à faire c'est maintenant
qu'il faut le faire
allons-y outre marine le pen molle ne me
mêler pas à des polémiques donc je ne
suis pas partie prenante j'en ai
suffisamment pour mon compte mais
franchement voix c'est cynique ce propos
de gérad arman assange
c'est une possédée la tactique
politisation des pics de débats commis
en avril
c'est un milieu souvent pour connaissez
bien la politique c'est habile ou pas
les gens sont suffisamment la polypill
pour penser qu'il faut en parler sur le
fond le reproche qu'on peut faire à
marine le pen c'est que ces ses prises
de position sont destinés à diviser le
pays à faire en sorte que flambent les
oppositions à l'intérieur du pays
c'est sûr c'est sur des questions qui
sont extrêmement difficiles
l'immigration l'identité
oui et qu'on doit traiter qu'on doit
traiter 1 mais qu'on doit traiter avec
la sérénité suffisante pour que au bout
du chemin
toutes les sensibilités reconnaissent
qu' on les a pris en charge réelle alors
franchement françois bayrou c'est bien
parce que vous me conduisait c'est moi
qui conduis là la question suivante est
ce que vous trouvez franchement la loi
dite séparatisme utile oui utile je
pense qu'il y appelait tu viens d'un
nombre de deux mères ou d'administration
oui qui sont désarmés devant des
conduites qui sont des dérives alors
pourquoi tant de réticences des autres
de toutes les nations eux aussi ils
françois bayrou si bon
le qu'est ce que dit cette loi est au
fond qu'est-ce qu'une wii la grande
tradition de la laïcité française et
j'en parle
comme vous savez comme un défenseur de
la laïcité comme quelqu'un qui croyant
oui et donc qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette
loi elle dit il ya une séparation des
responsabilités et une religion ne peut
pas faire la loi
une religion c'est une fois ce très
important pour les familles pour des
personnalités
mais la religion accepte de vivre dans
cette danse est france dans laquelle la
loi et pour tous et la foi de chacun est
respecté mais lors des débats de quoi on
parle essentiellement pendant quinze
jours du voile ou pas du voile de
franchement vous allez trouver les
débats à la hauteur à la hauteur du
problème
j'aime pas jugé comme ça non moi je juge
en tout cas je juge une chose vous dites
vous dit pardon joue coupe françois
bayrou parce que sur ces questions là je
vous c'est très très en pointe lors des
sorties scolaires peu importe que
certaines mamans soient voilées
expliquent les responsables des écoles
catholiques qui parfois catholique sous
contrat qui parfois ont 70 % d'élèves de
confession musulmane dans les parents
sont musulmans voilà ce que dit ses
responsables et ses responsables
d'écoles catholiques disent que viennent
chercher ses parents musulmans ils
viennent chercher l'espérance un endroit
où l'on parle de dieu à l'endroit où
l'on parle de dieu oui vienne succès ils
viennent chercher du du respect du
respect et
franchement le le la manière dont on
enseigne et dont on parle
oui des enfants qu'on a en face de soi
et de leurs parents ça devrait être le
bien commun de l'école privée et de
l'école laïque de l'école publique
ça devrait être la même chose partout
devant air de famille avant le foulard
pour bien sûr pour moi la laïcité c'est
ça la laïcité ça veut dire qu'il y a une
compréhension mutuelle qu'on comprend ce
que c'est une mère de famille issue
d'une tradition qu'on comprend ce que
c'est un enfant qui cherche à saint
émancipée assez assez souvent
comprenez le l'autre nom de la laïcité
c'est le respect françois bayrou est ce
que l'islamo gauchisme gangrène la
société et l'université qui n'y seraient
pas imperméable c'est ce que dit la
ministre valérie vidal bon jeu j'observe
beaucoup l'université français oui oui
et ça ne me paraît pas être le premier
problème de l'université française
on est aujourd'hui devant des questions
qui sont des questions extrêmement
lourdes avec des étudiants qui n'ont pas
vu d'enseignants physiquement depuis des
mois et des mois et c'est
particulièrement grave pour les
étudiants qui entrent qui entre pour la
première fois l'université dans lesquels
des moments dans lesquels la vie se joue
on découvre et les amis on se fait des
amis pour la vie
certains sont épanouis donne sont
introvertis on du mal à rencontrer c'est
souvent la première fois qu'ils sortent
de leur famille et tout ça en même temps
qu'on découvre une discipline une pensée
et une science qui se fait aussi à
l'université par la recherche
et bien ce le sentiment qui est le mien
c'est que
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui considérer
que l'université soit devant ce genre de
questions centrées perpétuellement
autour de l'islam ou d'une religion
c'est pas comme ça que je le ressens en
tout cas dans les universités que je
connaissais pas comme ça que ça se passe
j'ai une dernière saison françois bayrou
sur la relance parce que on parle des
étudiants qui souffrent pour beaucoup la
relance est roulante vous plaidé pour un
plan de reconquête de l'appareil
productif que vous allez présenter
oui je vais d'abord présenté dans les
heures qui viennent
oui quelques jours qui viennent une note
sur la dette que comment peut-on assumer
la dette qu'on a été obligés de
contracter
oui pour la solidarité pour sauver le
pays devant l'épidémie et pour soutenir
un certain nombre d'activités on vient
de parler de l'aéronautique sur votre
sur votre écran avec la catastrophe que
ça suppose et l'espoir conac ça reparte
mais ce l'observation que je fais celles
ci on a le modèle sociale le plus
généreux du monde
oui simplement un modèle social il faut
qu'ils puissent être financés et nous
n'avons plus l'appareil productif qui
permet de financer ce modèle social or
il faut donc un plan d'urgence appelle
ça un plan marshall de reconquête de
l'activité productive de l'industrie de
l'agriculture des services pour qu'on
ait la capacité de porter ce modèle
social on ne peut pas accepter que la
france
c'est terrible à dire soit et le
commerce extérieur qui fait que nous
avons 65 ou 75 milliards de déficit du
commerce extérieur
pendant que l'allemagne à 220 milliards
d'excédents du commerce extérieur
allemand sont pas plus fort que nous le
plan présenté
oui on a deux
impératif auquel il faut répondre
premier impératif comment finance-t-on
les les les dizaines centaines de
milliards qu'on a dépensé pour la
solidarité
et deuxièmement comment finance-t-on le
plan de reconquête qui fasse que notre
production et notre production
industrielle remonte peu à peu dans le
produit intérieur du pays pour qu'on
puisse assumer notre rang d'abord et
notre financement du modèle social merci
françois vaillant ou versier revenus de
voir ce matin rmc bfm tv